we've dealt with the weak acid so let's
try an example with the weak base so
let's say we had ammonia ammonia it's
nitrogen with three hydrogen's and it's
a weak base because it likes to accept
hydrogen's and from water leaving the
water with just a hydroxide so it
increases the hydroxide concentration so
if you have some ammonia in an aqueous
solution plus water I mean you can kind
of well out though the water in there
plus water NN aqueous solution it's a
weak base so it doesn't this this
reaction it doesn't go in just one
direction it's an equilibrium reaction
it's an equilibrium with and since this
is a weak base it and you know this is
where the the bronsted-lowry definition
really kind of pops out is that it
accepts its a proton acceptor instead of
a donor so you it turns into ammonium or
an ammonia cation ammonium has another
hydrogen on it so now it has has another
proton so it's a plus charge
that's an aqueous and took that hydrogen
from the water so plus o h minus aqueous
and remember if you look at it from the
bronsted-lowry definition it was a
proton acceptor so that meant that made
it a base or if you look at it the
reading it's definition it increased the
concentration of O H in the solution so
that makes it an Arrhenius base but
anyway given that we have on let me pick
up pick a random number let's say we
have point so we have point point two
molar of nh3 what is going to be the pH
so what's going to be our pH of this
solution considering that it's 0.2 molar
of nh3 so the first thing we need to do
we need to figure out the equilibrium
constant for this base reaction and I
would just went to eat liquid went to
equip I went to Wikipedia I want to say
liqui pedia
I'm talking about liquid so much I went
and an equilibrium equip idea but I went
to Wikipedia and you can look up they
have a little chart for almost any
compound you look for today they give
you p kb p k b which is you see that p
there that just means it's the minus log
base 10 of the equilibrium constant of
their of the on of the of the
equilibrium constant and they give that
as being four point seven five so we can
just do a little bit of math here to
solve for the equilibrium constant so
let's see if we put multiplied both
sides by a negative you get log base 10
of our equilibrium constant for this
base reaction that's why the B is there
is equal to minus four point seven five
or ten to the minus four point seven
five should be KB so K B is equal to ten
to the minus four point seven five
that's not an easy exponent to figure
out in your head so I'll bring out the
calculator for that so if we take ten to
the four point seven five minus it
equals one point seven let's just say
one point eight times 10 to the negative
five this is equal to one point eight
times ten to the minus five so now we
can use this information and and we can
do a mathematical thing very similar to
what we did in the last video to figure
out well it's going to be hard to figure
out the hydrogen concentration directly
right because our equilibrium reaction
only has hydroxide but if we know the
hydroxide concentration then we can back
into the hydrogen concentration knowing
that this plus the hydrogen
concentration has to equal or at least
the has to equal 10 to the minus 14th or
if you figure out the Poh that plus the
pH has to be 14 so when we did that a
couple of video go video z' ago so this
this equilibrium constant or these
formula would look like this 1.8 times
is 1.8 times times 10 to the minus 5
will be equal to
in the denominator we have our
concentration of reactants remember you
don't include the solvent so you only
include the nh3 we have two point two
molars what we put in but some of it
let's say X of it is going to be
converted into this stuff on the right
hand side so in the denominator we're
going to have point two - whatever it
gets converted into the right-hand side
and so then the right-hand side we're
going to have X of nh4 and X of O H so
this is this is the concentration of
ammonia and then we have x times X this
is the concentration of NH four plus
that's a four and then this is the
concentration right here of Oh H of Oh H
- right and we just solve for X so let's
do that solve for x and notice we have X
we know the concentration of O H we'll
be able to figure out the Poh and then
we'll be able to figure out the pH okay
multiply this times both sides of this
equation and just so you know that same
simplification step that we did in the
previous thing when this is several
orders of magnitude smaller than this
right here this is point then this
number right here you can you will I
don't want to I don't want to give you
your wrist here sticks are just kind of
rules of thumb that sometimes work let's
just do the quadratic equation but you
can kind of think about sometimes when
you might get rid of that middle term
but let's just multiply 0.2 times 1.8 is
0.36 0.36 times 10 to the minus 5 right
2 times 1.8 would be three point six
this is 0.36 minus 1.8 times 10 to the
minus 5x right is equal to that x
squared let's put everything on the same
side of the equation so you get I'm
going to move all of these to the right
hand side so you get 0 is equal to x
squared add this to both sides of this
equation
the equation plus 1.8 times 10 to the
minus 5x let me put this in turn 1.8
times 10 to the minus 5 so you can see
the coefficients to separate from the X
terms minus 0.36 times 10 to the minus 5
so let's solve this and once again if
you wanted to kind of do it you could
kind of you could you could eliminate
this term and then just figure out the
straight-up square root but we won't do
that well actually use a quadratic
equation so this is a is 1 B is this
that's B and this is C and you just
apply that in the quadratic equation so
you get minus B so you minus 1.8 times
10 to the minus 5 power plus or minus we
only have to do the plus because if we
do the minus 1 up with a negative
concentration so plus the square root a
lot of math here B squared so it's 1.8
times 10 to the negative 5 so it's one
point eight if you square it three point
two four so it's three point two four
times if you square 10 to the minus 5
this 10 to the minus 10 minus 4 times a
which is 1 times C which is minus so
it's 4 times the minuses cancel out
times 0.36 times 10 to the minus 5 which
is let's see 4 times 4 times 0.36 is
equal to one point four four I should
have been able to that in my head now
you have one point 4 4 e minus 5 times
10 2 so let me write that so you have so
this is one point 4 4 and of course all
of this is over 2a 2 so let's see and
these are going to be our this is my x
value my concentration of Oh H so let's
see I have 3 point 2 4
times 10 to the minus 10 that's that
plus plus one point four four times ten
to the minus five is equal to that so
that's this whole thing under the
radical and I want to take the square
root of that and so that is to the 0.5
power so I get point zero zero three
seven nine so I'll switch colors so I
get X is equal to minus one point eight
times ten to the minus five plus point
zero zero three seven nine four all of
that over to let's do the math so this
is so to that I'm going to subtract
minus this point right here I have this
value I'm to subtract this minus one
point eight e5 negative is equal to that
so this is the whole numerator and I
want you to just divide it by two
divided by two is equal to this is point
zero zero one so let me write that so X
so I'll switch colors arbitrarily again
X is equal to point zero zero one eight
eight eight I mean it's a three and so
forth and so on but if we remember from
our original equation what was X it was
well it's both the ammonium
concentration and the hydroxide
concentration we care about the
hydroxide concentration so this is equal
to my concentration of hydroxide now if
I want to figure out my Poh I just take
the minus log of this number which is
equal to so let's just take the log of
it the log is that and then I take the
minus of that so it's two point seven
two so it's two point seven two and now
if we want to figure out the pH so how
much high Hydra my concentration of
hydrogen
ion's just remember when you're in an
aqueous solution at 25 degrees Celsius
your PK of water is equal to your P o H
plus your pH this at 25 degrees is 14
because you have 10 to the minus 14
molar concentration well actually I
don't want to go into that you have 10
to the minus 7 of each of these but
anyway this is the equilibrium constant
for the disassociation of water this
it's when water's neutral is 10 is 7 or
a concentration of O H of 10 to the
minus 7 when we take the minus log this
becomes 7 but now we know we have a much
higher concentration of O H 2.7 to
remember that minus log kind of flips it
so a lower Poh means a higher
concentration of Poh right and a lower
Poh if this is lower right this is a
lower Poh that means your pH is higher
with you and then I'll I don't want to
confuse you too much so what does your
pH going to be so your pH is going to be
equal to equal to 14 minus 2.7 to let me
do the minus plus 14 is equal to 11
point let's just say eleven point three
so your pH is equal to eleven point
three which makes sense because we said
this was a weak base ammonia is a weak
base so it's basic so it should increase
your pH above the northern neutral seven
so the pH should be greater than seven
but as you compare it to some of the
strong bases before that took our pH
when you added a molar to 14 this took
our pH although we only did it add point
two molar of it to eleven point three
anyway this is a more of a math problem
than chemistry but hopefully it
clarified a few things as well